BRIAN: NEW REPORT SHOWS PEOPLE
WHO WHO ALREADY HAD THE
CORONAVIRUS GETTING IT AGAIN?
IN SOUTH KOREA 116 PATIENTS WHO
RECOVERED FROM COVID-19 HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE A SECOND TIME.
DOES THIS MEAN THE VIRUS CAN
REACTIVATE OR WAS IT NEVER
ACTUALLY OUT OF THE SYSTEM?
DR. MARC SIEGEL IS HERE.
DR. SIEGEL, WHAT DOES THIS MEAN
FOR IMMUNITY?
>>
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
REASSURE PEOPLE I BELIEVE IN THE
VAST MAJORITY OF CASES ONCE
YOU’VE HAD COVID-19 YOU’RE
LIKELY OVER IT AND HAVE
ANTIBODIES AND CAN YOU FIGHT IT
OFF AGAIN FOR A PERIOD OF TIME.
IF WE BASE IT ON SARS, WHICH IS
A VERY SIMILAR VIRUS FROM 2003,
THAT PERIOD OF TIME WOULD BE A
COUPLE OF YEARS.
BUT, BRIAN, WE DON’T HAVE ALL
THE INFORMATION YET.
AND THE PEOPLE IN SOUTH KOREA
ARE PUT FORTH WHAT YOU ALREADY
SAID.
MAYBE THEY NEVER GOT OVER IT.
MAYBE THOSE PATIENTS HAD AN
IMMUNE PROBLEM WHERE THEY
COULDN’T DEVELOP AN IMMUNITY OR
MAYBE THEY DIDN’T DEVELOP ENOUGH
OF WHAT WE CALL NEUTRALIZING
ANTIBODY.
THAT’S A WORD YOU HAVE NEVER
HEARD BEFORE.
THAT’S WHAT SCIENTISTS ARE
LOOKING FOR.
ARE YOU DEVELOPING THE KIND OF
ANTIBODIES THAT NEUTRALIZE THE
VIRUS THAT PREVENT IT FROM EVER
GIVING YOU ANOTHER INFECTION?
THAT’S THE BASIS OF THE VACCINE
RIGHT THERE THAT THEY ARE
WORKING ON.
NEUTRALIZING ANTIBODIES.
WE DON’T HAVE THE COMPLETE
SCIENCE ON IT YET, BRIAN, BUT I
THINK IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CASES WHEN YOU ARE OVER, THIS
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET IT
AGAIN.
BRIAN: WHAT IS THE MOST
ENCOURAGING THING YOU ARE
HEARING WHAT COMPANY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE VACCINE?
>> WELL, I THINK THE IDEA THAT
THE MADERNA VACCINE IS ENTERING
THE END OF PHASE ONE CLINICAL
TRIALS.
DR. FAUCI OHIO SPOKE TO ABOUT
THIS THE OTHER DAY.
IT’S GOING TO GET INTO PHASE 2
VERY SOON.
IT LOOKS LIKE IT’S HITTING THE
TARGET, THAT IT’S REALLY
WORKING.
THEY ARE VERY OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
IT.
IT’S NOT ONLY THE MADERNA
VACCINE.
SOME OF THE OTHER PHARMACEUTICAL
JOHNSON AND JOHNSON AND OTHER
MAJOR PLAYERS INVOLVED IN THIS
IS AN THAT FAY.
WE WILL SEE WHERE WE END UP.
IT’S GOING TO TAKE A WHILE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO GIVE IT TO
A LOT OF PEOPLE, MAKE SURE THAT
IT’S EFFECTIVE AND THEN THE
MANUFACTURING PROCESS, BRIAN,
COSTS AT LEAST A BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE BEGINNING TO TO THE
END.
A LOT OF MONEY INVOLVES.
BRIAN: YOU WILL MAKE A LOT OF
MONEY TO.
IF YOU DO THIS 180 COUNTRIES AND
EVERY CONTINENT WANT TO ORDER
FROM YOUR COMPANY.
>> YOU BET.
BRIAN: DR. SIEGEL, I WATCHED YOU
LAST NIGHT WITH TUCKER.
YOU REALLY THOUGHT THIS COUGH
COULD HAVE BEEN THE CORONAVIRUS.
SO YOU TOOK THE TEST ON CAMERA.
IT WAS A 15-MINUTE TEST.
AND WE GOT THE ANSWER BEFORE HIS
SHOW WAS OVER.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
>> IT WAS NERVE-RACKING BECAUSE
I WANTED TO MAKE THE POINT THAT
I, LIKE EVERYONE ELSE, HAS A
COUGH.
WE THINK WE HAVE IT.
AND SOME OF US DO HAVE IT.
SOME DON’T.
AND THAT’S WHY I REALLY WANT THE
RAPID TEST TO BE MORE AVAILABLE.
NOT JUST THE TEST I TOOK ON
CAMERA LAST NIGHT.
I ACTUALLY HAD A REALLY GREAT
LABORATORY PATHOLOGIST COME ALL
THE WAY DOWN FROM BOSTON GIVE
THAT TEST IN FULL GARB, YOU SAW
THAT.
NEGATIVE WITHIN 15 ANYONE’S 15 M
NOW I’M GOING TO HAVE MY
ANTIBODIES FIRST POINT TO SEE IF
I COULD HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO
PREVIOUSLY THAT WILL SHOW EVEN
MORE IF I ACTUALLY HAVE HUMIDITY
OR I NEVER GOT IT.
WE NEED EVERYBODY TO KNOW THAT
THIS THING IS SO CONTAGIOUS.
DID YOU GET IT.
WERE YOU EXPOSED TO IT?
ARE YOU OVER IT?
THOSE ARE THE KEY QUESTIONS NOW.
BRIAN: SO, DR. SIEGEL, WHAT I
GET WHEN I WALK AROUND AND
EVERYONE SAYS THIS.
EVERYONE HAS THE SAME QUESTION.
I WANT TO FIND OUT IF I HAD IT.
I WILL GIVE PLASMA IF I HAVE
IMMUNITY FOR IT AND WHEN CAN I
GET THE QUICK TEST?
WHAT DO YOU SAY WHEN PEOPLE ASK
YOU THESE VERY FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTIONS?
>> I THINK WE NEED A MARSHALL
LING OUT OF THAT RAPID TEST THAT
YOU SAW ME SHOW LAST NIGHT.
THAT TEST IS ONLY 18,000 OF THEM
IN THE COUNTRY.
THEY CAN ONLY DO 4 PER HOUR IN
THE MACHINE.
I THINK WE NEED A BIG ROLLOUT
AND EVEN ABBOTT OR OTHER
COMPANIES HAVE TO GIVE US MORE
OF THAT RAPID TEST.
THAT’S THE TEST, CALL POINT OF
CARE DO YOU HAVE IT NOW IN THE
ANTIBODY TEST, BRIAN, IS A
DIFFERENT PROBLEM WHICH IS WE
NEED TO DEVELOP ACCURACY.
THIS 70 DIFFERENT COMPANIES THAT
ARE AND LABS THAT ARE TRYING TO
GET APPROVAL FOR THOSE ANTIBODY
TESTS.
WE NEED A STANDARD ONE.
AT LEAST A FEW DIFFERENT
COMPANIES.
NARROW IT DOWN TO THE ONES THAT
TELL US THE MOST ABOUT WHAT YOUR
CHANCES OF IMMUNITY ARE.
AND GET IT OUT TO EVERYONE.
THE NIH IS CURRENTLY DOING A
STUDY OF 10,000 PEOPLE TO SEE
HOW FAR COVID-19 HAS SPREAD INTO
COMMUNITIES.
THE ANTIBODIES ARE THE WAY TO
TELL THAT.
THE BLOOD TEST I TOOK LAST
NIGHT, I WILL HAVE THE ANSWER
TODAY.
I WILL KNOW IF I WAS EXPOSED TO
THIS OR NOT, I NEED EVERYBODY TO
KNOW THAT.
BRIAN: ABSOLUTELY.
DR. SIEGEL, THANKS SO MUCH,
APPRECIATE IT.